Michael help us here we've got a
Thanksgiving table to be at soon we've
got a Christmas table to be at soon or
anything in between politics or no
politics I didn't think it was possible
but Whoopi Goldberg is 100% correct
she has nailed it if this is true Joy
Behar is exposing one of the worst
aspects of second wave feminism and the
left broadly which is that the personal
is the political there's this erosion of
the difference between the private and
the public there was a McLaughlin and
Associates poll
it showed that 75% of Americans hate the
politicization of entertainment we don't
like speaking about it all the time we
don't like speaking about it over the
dinner table the left however always
brings this up over the holidays the
Obama administration a few years ago
insisted they sent out a campaign
material that said that you should speak
about Obama care with your uncle at the
dinner table this is because holidays
are holy days conservatives broadly
would rather use those holy days to
honor God give thanks for their family
and but for the left their God is
politics and they honor him at every
single holiday table
Michael I want to ask you something
about what Tim Allen recently said to
indieWIRE he said and I quote I think
it's funny to make fun of people that
are full of themselves liberals have a
very small window of sense of humor
about themselves so I love poking at it
what do you think about that I've often
found that liberals because they view
politics as their entire being they do
have a hard time kind of laughing at
themselves have you found that to be
true well you know it would be my
favorite hobby to poke fun at liberals I
wrote a best-selling book about this
series right Amy oh thank you very much
it was clearly a scholar Tim Allen shows
is that there's a difference between a
character and a person you know he said
now it's so much fun to make fun of
liberals this wasn't always the case now
it is and so you know he uses politics
to advance the plot of his show but I
think sometimes when it comes to the
left they're using their shows to
advance their politics so this reminds
me of Murphy Brown taking shots at Dan
Quayle for instance in the 1990s and
what is the left doing they're rebooting
that
Zach show they seem not to have learned
that lesson but it's very very tedious
when they do that that's a great point
using a show to advance politics as
opposed to using politics to advance
your show there's no one else out there
poking fun at liberals or promoting to
the sort of the center-right views of
Fox picks up Tim Allen he does so at
rates pretty darn well that's exactly
right there's a demand in the market
because the entire culture is left-wing
especially the entertainment culture in
Hollywood and New York so when you get
that one conservative character it's a
lot of fun I imagine if the situation
were reversed then the Left could have a
good time poking fun at conservatives
but right now the left cannot take
itself lightly it insists that
everything is a crisis democracy is
falling apart we're living in the freest
most prosperous most just time in the
history of the world and so when Joy
Behar says that democracy is at stake
it's hard to take her seriously she's
being funny but unintentionally so
trumped arrangement that's what it is
Trump remember he's got a book that
could be good dust bucking so Hayes
Turner you know it rid reasons to vote
for Democrats thanks Tony my good thanks
Michael Michael thank you very much
appreciate it